Harrison Salisbury in your new book
Tiananmen diary 13 days of June you
write that maybe the China Chinese
leaders call for the elimination of
chopsticks with a replacement of the
knife and fork may have caused this
whole thing explain that well it's a
long train of circumstances but you're
talking about who you bang who is the
General Secretary of the Communist Party
and a few Yin man a man with a brilliant
mind and flashing new ideas all the time
I spent some time with him and it's
great was great fun to be with him
because he spoke his mind whatever came
into it in Israel was one of those mines
and ranges over all possible subjects
great reader in having things translated
into Chinese and one day it must have
popped into his mind or maybe even
thinking of it for some time in the
course of a speech he said it was time
for China to abandon chopsticks
they were insanitary they're old
fashioned they were a symbol of the old
China and take up knife and fork well it
caused a furore in China and even
outside of China many people it's a man
talking about chopsticks or the essence
of China in China it was used against
him politically what kind of a man is he
how can he be the leader of the
Communist Party when he wants to China
to throw away his chopsticks and start
using knives and forks it just shows you
said his critics that he's not ready to
be trusted he isn't he isn't stable no
stable leader he would come up with
something like that well since who you
bang was already under attack for
innovation for being a progressive and
one thing another this turned out to be
a very valuable political weapon used
against him and it played a role in his
downfall when he was dismissed by a dump
shopping after many students were
demonstrating in Tiananmen Square in
support of reform and more progress in a
dialogue all the things which who you
bang stood for and this was then put
together who you bang the
Antti chopstick man who you bang who
caters to the students yet ruin and
indeed he was dismissed and he went into
retirement and on the fifteenth of April
of this year he died and the students
who had never forgotten him and who
still thought of him as their champion
even if he was against chopped steak so
went into the streets first of all they
started demonstrating in Beijing
University and then they marched up once
again to chin London Square and that's
how this whole critical episode of a
lengthy demonstrations and the
eventually ended by the army being
brought into the square on the third and
fourth of June that's how it all began
and what was his position in China and
and when was he in that position he was
the general secretary of the communist
party under dung shopping and he was
appointed general secretary I believe
I'm not absolutely sure but I think it
must have been about some time in the
early 80s he had been leader of the
Communist Youth Organization he'd been a
an ally of Deng Xiaoping from the very
earliest times when done fell during the
Cultural Revolution and was putting into
protective custody and in jail and
paraded around with a dunce cap on his
head who you bang suffered exactly the
same fate and the dung regarded him is a
very reliable and very able ally put
enormous tasks before him and dung his
choice was right he was a very
interesting and able man but dung
saddled him with responsibility for many
of the defects that had appeared in his
administration and that was what is
that's how he came to fall from power
did you know him I did indeed I one of
the most delightful evenings I ever
spent I spent with who you buying first
of all had a long formal interview and
then he invited me and my wife a couple
other people to dinner in John non-high
the leadership
pal the place which was a center of so
much activity during the gentleman
affair and we we had what he called an
American dinner
it wasn't an American dinner at all it
began with escargot and he was very
proud of I've served with a proper
French tools for eating snails we had a
marvelous filet mignon we had French
pastries it was a French meal really but
he kept calling it an American meal it
was he was determined to show us that
that he was moving into the Western
world it was a symbolic meal no one he
had not invited any of the diplomats or
anybody like that to dinner with him and
we were the first ones to come and have
dinner with who you're buying and he
deliberately staged this occasion to
show how Western he was this was the
kind of style that he wanted to bring it
to China it fit in with his attack on
chopsticks incidentally it was served by
waitresses who were very smart and very
chic at a time when there was no such
thing in China they wore the traditional
Chinese gowns sort of plum colored with
the slit skirt right up to the knee and
I noticed one of these rather lovely
young ladies kept the city is standing
behind who you're buying and I couldn't
understand why until I saw how excited
he got in his conversation is he got
excited he kept moving forward on his
chair further and further and more and
more animated until you thought he might
just leap into the air and perhaps he
has on some occasions anyway she was
there to be sure that he got back into
his seat and didn't fall on the floor
and I thought it was a wise precaution
it's one of the most interesting
evenings I've ever had he got onto all
kinds of subjects and one of the things
he asked me on that occasion he said who
was the greatest American president
after World War two and I thought a bit
and I said
well it's hard for me to choose it
perhaps was Eisenhower perhaps it was
Truman and it might have been Kennedy
he's oh no you're all wrong it was
Richard Nixon Richard Nixon was the
greatest man and he made the opening to
China
he said Nixon is my friend we correspond
I said you do oh yes he said we
exchanged letters regularly about once a
month and he sends me all his books and
I said do you read them oh yes he said I
haven't translated into Chinese and I've
read all of his books he's a very wise
statesman I said well do you send him
some books he said oh yes I send him
things which I think he would be
interested in reading and there I fell
down as a reporter I failed to ask him
what books he sent to mr. Nixon and I
haven't gotten around to asking mr.
Nixon but I dearly like to know whether
Nixon read the books that that who
you're buying he sent to him were you
under the impression that who you bang
was a disciple of dong Xiao Peng he was
very much a disciple of junk shopping
but he was the kind of a disciple who
has his own category of interests as
well I wouldn't say that junk shopping
necessarily shared all of who you bangs
tastes but he obviously liked having an
idea man an action man with him to
stimulate the ideas of of the elders who
often were slow on picking up on things
he shared a personality in a sense with
the dong shopping because while dumb
shopping has done some very bad things
lately in the connection with the
massacre when he came into office in
1977 and 78 he was very much like who
you bang he was a young he was a older
man he was in his early 70s but he was
full of ideas and full of energy and he
also was the kind of a man who might
leap out of his chair the Chinese called
him the india-rubber ball because he had
lost power so often but he always
bounced back up full of energy and went
forward
to something else it was very apt
description of him and I think he was
exactly the kind of man that China
needed after the disaster Mao and the
terrible problems of the country faced
because he was bold in daring he he had
imagination he was quite willing to
bring into China all kinds of capitalist
devices devices from America from the
West anything which he thought would
help China move more rapidly into the
age of technology into the modern world
as it was he wasn't bothered by ideology
or anything of that kind
his most famous statement which most
people know around the world is that it
doesn't matter whether the cat is black
or white so long as it catches the mouse
and by that he simply meant if it works
we'll use it because that's what's more
important than something which is
written by marx maybe a hundred years
ago
Harrison Salisbury is here to talk about
his book and this is as of September 1st
in your book stores both hardback and
paperback small questions he how come
both came out at the same time well this
was an instant book and I don't know why
the publisher brought the two of them
out together but I think he wanted them
both available because he wanted this
book available to the public as quick as
possible
I wrote it very rapidly he published it
very rapidly it took me about a month to
write it it took him about a month to
publish it and I think that sets some
kind of a record in publishing and this
book is 176 pages long that's right I
want to talk about a personal thing with
you before we start off because one of
the things that and the audience at
Regis will know this it's a little bit
fast-paced you takes your breath away
you wonder how can somebody go this fast
and build as many places and and you and
ice before we went on camera I asked you
how old you were and you told me that
you're 80 that's right at at 80 years
old how do you get the energy to do
something like this and this and by the
way something like this is being in
Beijing in the middle of all this well I
don't know how I got the energy to do it
I think it's probably you
because it's what I've been doing all my
life I have been I started out in
newspaper work really as an agency
reporter and you may know that agency
reporters have to write very very
rapidly I mean they don't often we
didn't even have time to write the story
we had to dictate it without even
writing it I've always been used to
working hard and working very rapidly
and perhaps it becomes a ingrained after
years and years becomes a habit and I
think it's a good habit and it served me
well I've written a great deal in my
life and I couldn't have done it unless
I wrote rapidly it has its disadvantages
there are errors in in Jenin and diary I
don't think any there are no errors of a
major consequence but lots of little
facts name Spelling's and things like
that it was not well proof read there
wasn't time for that I didn't have time
to look everything up I just zipped it
off and here it is in your hands you
start off in the very beginning and it
says aboard Jay Al flight SMS Japanese
Airlines number five New York to Tokyo
6:00 p.m. June 1st 1989 did you know
something was up everyone did you know
something was up before you let over no
I didn't know anything was up I mean I
in general as everybody did I knew that
there was a a certain amount of tension
in Beijing the students had been in the
square since the 15th of April or
shortly thereafter but I wasn't going
over there was to have anything to do
with them I was going over to work on a
documentary which would deal with the 40
years of the People's Republic which
will be celebrated the 40th anniversary
be celebrated on the 1st of October and
it was sure coincidence that we and
Japanese crew that I was working with
chance to arrive in Beijing on the 2nd
of June which was less than 48 hours
before the troops moved into the square
it did position me in in room 735 on
Chang'an Avenue in the Beijing hotel
which has a view right up the square
which is about a block and a quarter
block and a half to the west but I
didn't have that room because I thought
something was going to happen out there
that I
look at it just chanced to put me there
with a front row seat on what turned out
to be one of the the big stories of
certainty about of the year how did it
come that NHK the Japanese television
network had hired you to do this
documentary
well they began talking to me about that
about a year ago and the reason that
they came to me was that I am very well
known as a specialist in China I have
just done a great deal of work in the
field and they knew of my work they
wanted somebody who had some background
who could treat China from a historical
basis they didn't want simply spot
reporting they have very good reporters
of their own but they wanted somebody
who could put it in historical
perspective who could understand or try
to understand and explain how the
People's Republic came into being
where Chairman Mao came from in the red
army and what they hoped to do in that
period of time and also to to enumerate
their achievements and also their
failures because there were failures
right along with their achievements
certainly and I think that's why they
came to me and we discussed the general
ideas and the outline of this
documentary and found that we had in
general the same ideas about an approach
I had I had a free hand really to what
was to go into it and all the rest of it
and so we formed a partnership and I
drafted an outline of the important
events which I thought we should show
photographically if possible and the
kind of a scenario and chronology we
should go through and we came to a
general agreement and we did a great
deal of work on that documentary before
going to China we did the historical
research which I did and they sent in
camera crews to photograph certain
geographical locations and places in
China which were important to this story
we did interviews with me in
New York on some of the historical
aspects of it and and also interviewed a
few people in the United States did all
of this preliminary work and had about a
month of shooting to do in China this
was going to be divided into three parts
they wanted to take some background
shots of myself in Jenin and square we
had no idea that other people who would
already be shooting in that square
before we got there we intended to
interview about a dozen very important
Chinese officials not necessarily in
position in power at the present time
some of them who had a historical role
in the People's Republic but some of
them were contemporary we expect you to
photograph an interview Xiao Jian he had
the man who was dismissed as party
secretary he'd agreed to be interviewed
and he was number one on our list and
then we had a certain amount of work to
do out in the countryside of locations
where I wanted to go and explain the
significance for example of the great
Wuhan bridge which was the first great
industrial accomplishment of the peoples
we probably the first monument as it
were to the building up of China which
had been done with the aid of the
Soviets and so we wanted to go there and
I wanted to stand out beside the bridge
and tell the history of it and what his
significance was things of that kind
that we were going to do so we had these
three different components we thought it
would take about a month and we by
coincidence arrived in Beijing before
just before the the troops opened fire
on the students in the square and the
whole city was taken over by the
so-called martial law troops and and
dissolved into fighting all over he was
impossible of course to do any work in
Beijing and we had to change our plans
in accordance with the actual situation
did you ever complete the documentary
yes the documentary has been completed
and it's not been completed the way we
envisage it since we never did get to
interview the people in beige
and we never did get to take pictures of
me in Tiananmen Square that is not of
that kind we have one on there's one on
the back of that book but it is with the
with the student demonstrators which was
not intended to be in the in the 40
years of the People's Republic at all
but we did put together a picture after
we left China a couple of weeks after
going in because we found it impossible
to do the work we'd come to do after we
left China and came back we immediately
put in a new request with the Chinese
for permission to return when conditions
were more peaceful and we'd be able to
do the work than we planned originally
and alas we did get permission finally
to go back but too late actually for the
from the technical side from the
Japanese they couldn't they could not go
in and take more pictures and get them
into the documentary and use it before
the 1st of October as they planned but
in anticipation that we might not get
back
we made a substitute picture as it were
we took all the material we had and we
had some beautiful stuff from the
Chinese historical archives that movie
shots of Mao coming into Beijing 40
years ago and things of that kind and
this has been put together in a
documentary with commentary by myself a
lot of it is what you call the language
voiceover since I'm not on the spot they
have photographs and I comment on the
photographs in that manner and a the
kind of the form of the documentary has
been changed it was going to be 2 1 or 2
hour shows it's now been made 1 hour and
a half
presentation it's pretty good not as
good as it would have been if we'd had
the chance to do all we wanted but it
will be presented to be presented on the
I think on the 28th of September in 1974
you retired from the New York Times
after how many years well I'd been with
The Times for about 25 years roughly
what have you done for the last 15 years
besides things like this well I
in the last 15 years
I have written a great many books and I
have I have traveled very extensively in
both Russia and and China I devoted
myself much more to China than to Russia
in that period of time because China has
sort of come front in center as it was
even before that time I was spending
more of my time on that on the Chinese
side and on the Russian side I suppose
I've written let me see I've written two
books of memoirs I have written the long
long march the untold story which was
the the story of mouths six thousand
mile Marla's martyr was a retreat from
Chiang kai-shek's forces with his Red
Army fifty years ago which gave the Red
Army and the whole Chinese communist
movement its its form and its strength
and it went on from that in a few years
to take over all of China with my wife
we went over the whole route very rough
back country in China and I wrote a book
about that the first time that is you've
been treated in that matter that book
incidentally became it did very well in
this country but it became a number one
bestseller in China and it made me very
very well-known in China because
practically everyone certainly among the
literati or the intelligence here the
military or the students has read the
long march it was it and Lee Iacocca's
books were bestsellers the same year
interesting interesting conjunction of
Chinese tastes and that probably is the
most important thing that I have done
since my retirement as history how many
times have you been to China Oh in in
the last fifteen years I suppose I've
been to China about a dozen times
usually four periods never for less than
six weeks and often as much as four or
five months and when you write and I
know this was a quickie but when you
write how do you normally do that these
are certain normally I do this I have a
project in mind you
take the long march which is a good
example of it and I have done my
research in this country which is in the
case of the long march since so very
little had been written about it I read
literally every single word in English
that had been written about the long
march I interviewed in the United States
those Americans who had some peripheral
connection with it who knew the leaders
of the March or something of that kind I
read up so that I knew who were the
figures in it who were still surviving I
wanted to talk to and indeed I sent in
to the Chinese a list of about 40 people
whom I wanted to interview little did I
know that on that list of 40 people
about eight of them were dead but that
was simply because they their deaths had
not been reported in the American press
and most of those people had been in
prison them I say too so I went to China
with a pretty good working knowledge of
what I wanted to find out what were the
controversial aspects of that March I
knew exactly where they went and was
going to follow the Rudi's all the way
along with the exception possibly of a
few places where the I me doubled back
and forth over the same territory I
didn't see I didn't see he need to be
literally follow every little mile that
they followed and I was dependent of
course on the Chinese to make the
appropriate arrangements to enable me to
go to these territories since the areas
were all closed normally to foreign
travel and foreign correspondents and I
got that and before I before I went I
had the assurances from the Chinese that
I would be able to do all the things I
wanted to do since I had been making
requests and import tuning them for
literally a dozen years on this project
they knew very well what I needed and I
said I'm not going to go until we have
this all in line and we did the result
of that was that that I spent in China
two and a half months tracing the route
not on foot as the Red Army went but by
Jeep and sometimes by mule and other
other conveniences
sometimes by foot but not very far and I
interviewed all of the surviving
important people who were on the march
or God at secondhand a picture of what
they did and I was able to get into the
Chinese archives they were very good
about that in digging out archives for
me I rejected their research many times
because it was not it was not complete
it was inconclusive or his
propagandistic I think I gave them a
pretty good lesson in what an American
newspaperman or researcher expects by
way of facts at least I was told this by
the Chinese that they'd never confronted
the necessity of finding out exactly
what had happened they'd taken the word
of somebody that this had happened to
that it happened it was a difficult
process you take notes as you go and you
take notes it's like more long I don't
use a tape recorder as most people do
these days except in exceptional
circumstances where extreme precision is
is needed on names or dates or places or
something of that kind and I'd and I'm
afraid that I might possibly make my
errors of that kind in this case I
didn't use the tape recorder very much I
didn't need to but I wound up with let
me see I wound up with probably twelve
or fourteen standard sized notebooks
very closely written of notes the
principal tasked for me with those notes
that your first thing to do I each
evening after taking my notes of the day
I would sit down at my old 1942
Remington portable typewriter and
transcribe those notes because my
handwriting is very poor and unless I
write transcribed
very quickly I'm very apt not to be able
to read my notes so I've learned to do
this arduous as it is after a day's long
day's work just sit down the time where
I still do that and I keep them in great
detail if I encounter circumstances
along the way along the path I keep
notes in the form of a jury
or a diary and the techniques which I
used or note-taking all the rest are the
ones that are used in Jenin and diary
literally literal diary let me show the
audience how you've done this book for
instance this is day 4 and as you can
see here it's Beijing hotel 4:30 a.m. is
this an exact account of day to day that
you wrote on the spot or did you write
this when you got back
no it's an exact account of what I did
our day to day an hour to hour and
minute by minute there is one slight
emendation when I copied my notes off
and I did copy these notes often when
the NRI described quite rapidly because
of wanting to be able to read them I I
hadn't originally intended to write a
book or anything that kind of was just
transcribing from my own interest or
what I might use them but I quickly
realized that indeed this would be a
book and it was ahead a historical
interest as I transcribed them in on
evenings and I had I had an evening in
Canton and one in Hong Kong and one in
Tokyo on the way back and then that long
train ride a plane ride when I could use
my typewriter I transcribed about half
of my notes and I put in identifying
material where I mentioned a name I
identified who it was and things of that
kind
other than that there is a no change I
didn't I didn't put any later wisdom
into the notes at any mistake in
apprehension or understanding is right
there in the book corrected later on in
the book if I was able to correction the
only material written after the period
of the 13 days came when I had completed
the transcription and I added a final
chapter of interpretation in which I
tried to explain as best I knew how what
had happened why hadn't happened what
were the political factors involved and
what the consequences might be see here
that that chapter I think was called a
fortnight later that's right
were you pretty tired when you got back
I was very tired but when I am writing
something like this it stimulates me a
lot
and I I find that I can go on working
for a good long time
the adrenaline begins to flow when you
got back and where is home home is up in
Northwest Connecticut in Taconic
Connecticut right up at the beginning of
the Berkshires and when you write what
time of day do you write the best well I
think I write the best probably between
4 a.m. and 7 a.m. when I'm writing
something like that I get up quite early
when the household is all asleep and I
have three or four hours of
uninterrupted work before breakfast and
then after that I can read over what
I've done and make the corrections and
editing and then go ahead and plow
forward and do what little research I
may have to do to write a coherent
narrative and that's more or less the
pattern that I followed on this book
what do you hope this book will do I
hope that it will it will give people a
precise account of exactly what happened
at Atia and men it will give them some
understanding of the forces at work in
Chinese society which the first place
produced the emotions and the drive that
propelled the students into what
amounted to a crusade as they would have
put it to improve their government not
to not to rebel against it or anything
else and the forces it stimulated with
in Chinese society and the political
structure which instead of adapting
itself and taking the opportunity to
move with the students instead rose up
and crushed them in an effort to
demonstrate that they still had the
power and that nobody could tell them
what to do I think it's very important
that we understand that because it's a
it this is a benchmark in Chinese
history as I understand Chinese history
and contemporary history under dung they
were moving very rapidly and very
effectively toward a new China China
which would would cast
off a great deal of the dross of the old
not all of it by any means but it would
move into contemporary techniques and
things of that kind
and take the first steps I so hoped
anyway on a democratic process and I
believe that the ten years the dung LED
China on the programme of reform and
opening the West were ten of the best
years that China has had certainly in
the modern day and then in one period of
a few hours this was blasted away I
don't mean the China is forever haunted
by this of course not China will pick up
the beat but they it's it it the
Tiananmen cost it China a great deal not
only done personally by destroying his
image to his people but China in general
because the political and economic
effects are very great I don't believe
anybody thought what these effects might
be but it will be a long long time
before China begins to move forward
again
as she was moving before that day and I
think we should understand that because
we're we're very apt to lose sight of
these things they get blurred over as
time goes on and the government has made
a great effort to try and present an
alternative version that there wasn't
any Chenin and there wasn't any massacre
that the we fall all lies on students to
some extent and then two categories
which I had them defined for me one are
bad men and one are bandits and the
students the bad men the bandits
conspired in a plot so they say to
overthrow dung and overthrow the
Communist Party
well there was no such conspiracy and I
think it makes it's clear to anybody who
reads that book that there wasn't we
know what the students are the bad men
as they defined it or bad men are people
who recently have been released from
prisons and who are capable of carrying
out criminal acts and some of the
students became bad men in the process
of this tiananmen affair
the bandits were the ones that
interested me most because when when
Chiang kai-shek
was struggling against Mao and his
Communists he called Mao and the
communist bandits and I wanted to be
sure that the present generation of
Communists were using the same word that
chung-kai shaggy used when they talked
about bandits and sure enough they are
using exactly the same term they mean a
slightly different category of enemy the
bandits are hardened criminals the ones
who destroy state property and not
likely to be students but they sometimes
are bad men bad men turn into bandits
and maybe students over a period of time
can do that well as you can see from my
explanation which seems to me at least
to be perfectly ridiculous they've they
have a whole language which they're
using to construct an alternate theory
about what happened in Chen on men far
as I know Chen and min was the
responsibility of the old man and dong
who ordered the army to fire on the
students and on the people in in Beijing
the only people who were manifesting any
any opposition to the government were
students the ordinary people of Beijing
and there were around the fringes of
this a few unemployed youths
they may be in the definition of the
government either bandits or bad man I
don't know how they define them but they
were unemployed because the government
couldn't find any work for them and they
joined in being idle they joined in what
was going on they didn't play any
important role in it I think we should
have all these things clearly in our
minds because it would be an era in
which this will all be passed and people
say well I mean did we have an
exaggerated idea to Dan Rather and his
cameras give us a picture that was false
in some way that's what the Chinese are
saying I don't think he did I think he
gave us a very accurate picture of these
young idealistic young people
he gave us at least a little glimpse of
the arbitrary action of which the regime
was capable when they pulled the plug on
his broadcasts and that was in a sense a
small forerunner of the kind of action
they would take when they would pull the
plug on the whole demonstration and tell
the troops to come in and blast their
way through by any means if you went
through the book and probably wrote down
the person's name that's mentioned the
most it would just from my looking
through it I'd be Charlotte who's
Charlotte Charlotte is my wife and the
reason that Charlotte is mentioned more
often than anything else in the book is
in the first place we're very close we
are normally when we go I go to China we
go together it's a it's a joint
operation when we're in this country
we're together and constantly during
this time knowing how troubled she would
be that I was in in what she would
perceive a situation of great danger in
so a while I picked up the telephone
which rely on the table of my my room
wherever I was in China and they have a
beautiful touch-tone system which was
installed a great extent they bought it
from France at the insistence of the
Chinese army so they have good
communication system and I use it to
call Charlotte in Taconic Connecticut
and I would get through to her in about
20 seconds and I could reassure her that
things were not as bad as they seemed
when she was looking on them tube and
she could tell me what was the latest
being shown on television in the United
States and keep me up to date
with the image that the people in the
United States were getting of what I was
seeing only part of with my own eyes
when you got back to Jude to sit down
and spend a lot of time chatting about
what you had seen versus what she had
seen yes we had we done that we did that
but quite honestly we had done a good
deal of it all the way along because I
called her every day and sometimes more
than every day and we traded impressions
as we went along when I came back she
gave me an overall summary or the
Hollywood seemed to her how did it seem
to her friends and various points which
stuck in her mind which we hadn't
discussed
things which perhaps I hadn't known
about one of the most interesting ones
of these was the following I after I got
out in the countryside and left these
James Charlie in the countryside I began
to be more and more aware of the element
of xenophobia of the effort that the
government was making to turn the blame
for everything on foreigners in
particularly United States and this was
a exasperated by the fact that we had
given refuge in the embassy to finally
gee the famous Chinese dissident and for
reasons I don't quite understand that
very name and that man is anathema to
dunk shot ping and the Chinese really
were vibrating about the idea of him
being in yeah in the embassy and they
were demanding that he be released
demanding all these different things and
it occurred to me I knew that we would
not release a man that we'd given
political embassy asylum to that the one
thing the Chinese might try was to seize
a hostage and looking around the country
all the Americans had left the country
about that time very few people left in
the embassy some regular working
newspaperman in in Beijing but I stuck
out like sort of like a sore thumb
because I was very prominent in China
and I thought the Chinese would think
well he's a very prominent person why
don't you grab him and then we could
work a trade I didn't really want to be
involved in anything of that kind and I
didn't say anything to Charlotte about
this because I didn't want her worrying
about that but lo and behold she got a
call one day from somebody who wanted to
know she had heard anything in the State
Department that I was in some personal
danger she was very upset by that and
then that very evening dan Rather
mentioned on the CBS broadcast that the
American the state department's worried
about the seizure of a hostage who might
be traded off for a final eg so I
realized then that this what I thought
was a vagrant thought in my mind
one which which really was in other
people's minds and one of the first
things I did when I got back to Taconic
was just sat down with Charlotte and
explained to her how this all had come
about and I didn't really know and I
don't know to this day how the State
Department got worried about that
question but I think it was simply using
the same kind of reason and logic that I
was using and analyzing the situation
what day did you leave Beijing hour left
Beijing on the fifth of the fifth of
June what day was the attack and the
attack was the third and fourth and
where did you go when you left well the
first thing we had to do is to get out
of Beijing which is not at all easy
because the Beijing hotel where we were
was was surrounded and barricaded we
were really prisoners in the hotel but
we got a a Chinese driver who was very
familiar with the little alleyway as the
hutongs that make up the central part of
Beijing and we managed to pick our way
through those back alleys until we
managed to get a a clear highway the
reason for the difficulty was there were
so many barricades across to all the
streets and so much military activity
and shooting that we didn't want to
driver didn't want to expose his car to
it and we didn't want to expose us to it
we got out to the airport which is
deserted because nobody could get out of
the sea and we flew down to Wuhan about
a two-hour flight out of out of Beijing
and there we begin a trip through the
countryside which enabled me to see how
the people outside of Beijing were
responding to the events and whether
indeed they knew what had happened in
Beijing they had their regular
commercial service still underway during
this time oh yes yes indeed and there
have been many rumors that the earth
service had been closed down but it
hasn't it for the first time in all of
years I've been going to China I rode on
a Chinese airplane that was not filled
the Chinese Airlines had a I think a
practice of not flying until they'd sold
every seat in the plane
but they couldn't sell them all now and
what was your reason for going out into
the country after you'd been in Beijing
during this period and did you take all
your Japanese camera crew with you yes
we went out to fulfill the the
countryside segments of our our planned
itinerary we went out to to film in
various cities that were important to
the history of the People's Republic to
interview people in various these
various locations the first place we
went to is Wuhan or the famous bridge
across the Yangtze had been built and we
found that Wuhan had been the scene of
some very big manifestations in fact
they were still going on when we arrived
there they've been there had been big
demonstrations in Wuhan on the very
afternoon and Sunday afternoon after the
after the massacre
already word had reached Wuhan and the
students had come out and carried out a
demonstrations and large crowds gathered
we went into the heart of town and found
that we could hardly get through the
shopping a center because there were
four big meetings being held by students
and there were big posters on the walls
telling about what had happened in
Tiananmen and listing the names of Wuhan
students who had been killed in the in
the massacre we drove out in the town
and discovered we bumped into a big
funeral parade coming back that Hill
held a ceremony for the victims of Chen
on Menon had these great big Chinese
paper wreaths that they used for their
funerals and there must have been
several thousand people in in that and
so we knew immediately that that the
people in Wuhan at any rate which is a
great city of several million people
knew all about what had happened in the
square and as we went along deeper and
deeper into the countryside we found the
same thing was true all of this had been
gotten out there worried about what had
happened there had been gotten out by
the students ahead of the government
propaganda this is before the government
began to claim that nobody was killed
there was no massacre
gentleman and so we then found that
people had already gotten the truth in
their systems and when the government
lies began to kill OGG they were taking
his lies by the people they didn't send
up and shot about it but they knew
perfectly well the government was trying
to put something over on them and they
weren't buying it how did you stay in
touch with the outside world during that
time well I stayed in touch in two ways
one by shortwave radio I listen to the
BBC and the VOA constantly and also by
telephone calls to my colleagues in
Beijing and my Japanese colleagues has
called their correspondents in Beijing
or in Tokyo and so we were quite well
informed as to what was going on and
what kind of a job do you think the BBC
and the voi do I think they did a
magnificent job I was I was utterly
astounded from the very beginning at say
4:00 a.m. or 3:30 a.m. on on June 4th I
was in my hotel room and the Chang'an
Avenue was dark I could see movement
there I could hear the shooting from
IANA
Minh I couldn't tell at that moment
whether the troops had taken over the
square whether a battle was going on or
what and I flicked on the VOA and I got
the last part of a ver broadcast in
which they were saying the troops had
come into into the square and they had
been firing as they came in and a lot of
people had been killed so then I I could
interpret what was happening in the
square as as the day wore on again and
again when I was not clear as to what
was actually happening on the streets
after all I had limited vision only down
a few blocks to the east and a few
blocks to the west I would turn on the
radio or TV I didn't turn on the TV the
radio to either a BBC or VOA and see
what they were reporting and I found it
matched up exactly with what I was
hearing and seeing I think they did a
great job I don't know of anybody
outside of the Chinese government who
contends
that their reports were exaggerated in
any way sometimes they weren't entirely
accurate but you don't always have a
hundred percent accuracy in the middle
of a battle too much is going on and in
the earliest stages for example they
underreported the casualties that was
that was we all did that I myself
estimated I couldn't believe that more
than a hundred hundred and fifty people
at most have been killed and I was
astounded when I began to hear reports
of several thousand but this was because
I hadn't realized how many people had
been killed by the armored columns as
they plunged into the city with their
guns going into solid masses of people
and literally blasted their way through
those crowds after I had a couple of
first-hand descriptions of what happened
when the tanks and the armored troop
carriers came in then I could readily
see why the toll would be as high as
that it it needn't emit but if you're
going to go in and you're shooting
you've got an awful lot of targets to
shoot at by the way when did you have
your first discussion that this was a
book I mean you said that you didn't
start out thinking about oh well I tell
you I that came the day after I got back
to New York I I called my editor
Roger Donald and little brown and I said
I've got something to talk to you about
and he said I've got something to talk
to you about well it turned out we had
the same idea but Tienanmen diary he
didn't know I'd kept a diary but he
thought that a book on this subject a
quick book would be useful and I thought
suggest I've got it hath written he said
wonderful we're going to make that an
instant book so we've never tried that
before but we're gonna do it this time
because the interest is here we want the
book to come out while people are eager
to know exactly step-by-step what
happened so I said fine and I proceeded
then a to complete the book which I had
about half copied I completed the book
and wrote the the final chapter
explaining as best I could while I
thought it happened and all that
Carla progr and he came down from Boston
stopped off at Taconic and spent the day
editing something which I've never
handed an editor in my life this was the
raw copy I hadn't had it I haven't had
it copied over I hadn't copy it over
myself it was full of interlining all
the rest of it he said that doesn't make
a difference I'm a good editor I can I
can read all through all that and he did
and at the end of the day he said fine
it's a book and I had answered two or
three questions and put little inserts
in he took it away turned it into their
copy reading department and I believe
the day after the fourth of July it was
turned over to the printer and we had
bound books by the 4th or 5th of August
and actual publication date was
September 1st
yes publication was September 1st and is
it too late have things changed since
you finished this or do you find this
still relevant I think every word of it
is very relevant there are some things
which I found out since which are not in
the book and I wish they were more
details of how the troops blasted their
way in a little bit on the political
background a few little facts here and
there but there is nothing wrong in the
book the I think it has the the right
mood it has the right explanation for
why the Chinese acted as they did and I
think I have accurately portrayed the
response of the students and most
particularly of the people of Beijing
and at no time during this trip did you
find yourself out of Energy Department
someone out of energy we were able to
deal with all this jet lag and traveling
and all this kind of stuff I think when
you have something like this on your
mind and when you're when you're really
revved up about something you it gentle
eyes tends to vanish
I can't recall a chip in which I had
less problem with jet lag do you want to
go back to China yes very much so I I'm
working on a much bigger and broader
project than that you know and re what
I've been working on for the last three
years is a book on the dumb shopping
period in China essentially what has
happened in China since Mao died
when did he die he died in 76 in
September exactly 13 years ago this
month and he left China in a dreadful
state of chaos dong came in and he put
things together and he got China going
in a remarkable way and he had ten
straight years in which he did he
changed son in many ways as it hadn't
been changed in thousands of years he
brought prosperity to the countryside by
eliminating the communes and enabling
farmers to go into private farming and
private to business and make money
very good for China and then this comes
along an unfortunate and contradictory
end really to his career as something
which damages enormous Lee his
achievements and it will take them a
long time to pick up on it all of that
goes in this book which I'm now writing
about a third of that book was written
before China and dari and I have I think
all the essential research for the other
segments had all been blocked out last
three years I spent an awful lot of time
in China working on this but I should
get back and take the temperature again
and make some political soundings so
that I have a little bit more certain of
the direction in which China is is going
to emerge after dung passes from the
scene and hopefully get a little clearer
idea who his successor may be I'm not
sure this is accurate to tell me if I'm
miss reading it you got a sense that
going into this whole experience of you
being over there
that you thought the students were gonna
win you come out more pessimistic saying
it may be a long time you change your
view during this yes I did very much so
I thought that I thought from all I had
learned before going over there and
indeed what I learned after I got out it
got over there in the short period of
time
that I had it looked to me as all the
students were winning or at least their
ideas or winning they didn't necessarily
have to
that dialogue with the government they
might not have it but the government
which had the same general objectives
was going to be spurred and pushed along
in that direction by the student
movement and this I must say was the
view of my Chinese friends they all
believed that extraordinarily and beyond
their expectations this was what was
going to happen and they were almost
deliriously happy about it well as we
know I was wrong and they were wrong and
it all came to a bitter bloody end and
it's not going to be that way the next
round when it comes and I'm sure it's
going to come with dong his death is
going to be a struggle of a different
type it's going to be led I don't think
by students but by adults probably by
the people of Beijing I don't know who
their leaders will be they didn't have
any leaders in this in in the Ken and
min thing they were just all of them out
there but there are be leaders and the
army will not be one unit as it was
supporting dong but probably conflicting
generals and divisions may there may be
some civil war I don't know there may be
some splintering up of China at least
temporarily reversion I hope it doesn't
happen but some of the Chinese think
maybe a reversion to warlordism or
something of that kind out of it all I'm
sure there will come a new China which
will pick up the beat and continue to
march towards something better but it
isn't going to happen tomorrow and he's
going to happen two years from now I can
remember during the June the those days
that you write about a television
reporter standing in Tiananmen Square
saying China will never be the same
again yep
this thing before the military moved in
you think that the reporters were too
optimistic and do you think it ever will
be the same again well they are
absolutely right that China will never
be the same again but that isn't what
they were thinking about they were
thinking that China was going to be
the new China that would follow would be
in the model of what they saw in the
student movement and I remember very
well dan Rather saying that I remember
Betty Bob Lord the life of the
ex-ambassador saying where's the same
effect and I know many people many
China's scholars in this country and
particularly a lot of Chinese students
and younger Chinese saying that how can
so many people be so long well let me
give you another thing the Cultural
Revolution which lasted about ten years
and embraced probably undoubtedly the
worst atrocities that China has ever
seen and death of millions of people and
the disgrace and murder of some of our
top leaders when that was all over now
dead dung in power every Chinese I spoke
to of whatever generation whether it was
of dung generation or the new youngsters
just out of school said we've learned
our lesson there will never be anything
like the Cultural Revolution again they
were wrong because inherent in China and
men and in the lies the government is
telling are the same techniques which
were used in the Cultural Revolution how
can they how can people make these
mistakes I think they're made because
they miss read some essential ingredient
ingredients in human character they miss
read in particular what revolves around
power and the extent to which a man who
has power would use whatever means at
his disposal to hold that power even at
great cost
I see dung as having used the power of
the military and the force of the
military and the shooting down of his
own citizens as a visual and vivid
demonstration that he is still in charge
and he's able to run that country with
the help of the army in spite of
anything people say he's not alone in
that use of power to hold power I think
that one has to under
that anyone who has absolute power as it
tends to be true in a dictatorship like
China or the Soviet Union will in the
end use that power use the power of hill
to keep his personal power he identifies
with his country and we must remember
that here's what the book looks like
it's both in paperback and in hardback
Little Brown publishes it 10 amend I
read 13 days in June by Harrison he
Salisbury our guest for the last hour
thank you very much thank you